Welcome back, okay, it's time for our supersize pop quiz.
Yeah.
(bell ringing)
(audience whooping)
All right Nicole Hinckle, you have been selected.
Now yesterday you won a thousand dollars.
You can walk away with your $1,000 today,
or you can give it back to us right now.
And you can come back tomorrow to play a supersize pop quiz
for the chance to win five thousand dollars.
(audience clapping)
I will come back tomorrow.
Yesterday, but you gave it back and you risked it all.
Yup, you gave back the $1,000,
'cause we told you today
you'd have a chance at $5,000 dollars.
(audience clapping)
So, you're back to zero,
but for every question you answer correctly
you'll win $100.
If you get a second one, you'll get $200,
if you get all three right
you get $5,000.
(cash register bell ringing)
Right here, how about that?
Right Nicole, are you ready?
I am ready.
You have been on pins and needles,
you've been waiting for this.
I have.
All right, I have too.
All right, first question.
How many times did Marie Osmond marry her husband?
By the way, I remarried my first husband
and so it's like honeymoon all over again.
But now I'm I wanna back out on the road.
Two.
That's right.
That's right, $200.
(Bell tinging)
(Audience cheering)
That's exactly right.
Okay, second question.
Which shoe did we pick during Drew and A?
What shoe do you think will be the most impressionable
walking in to like an interview or something,
for the fashion industry?
I say the more fun the better.
I would do the red boot.
I'm all about the red boot.
Red boot.
The red boot.
Yes.
That's right.
(Bell ringing)
(Audience cheering)
That's $200.
(audience clapping)
Okay.
I'm Sorry, I just get too invested.
(all laughing)
It all comes down to this for $5,000.
How often do dermatologists say
that you should be washing your pillow case?
You're supposed to wash your pillow cases every day.
Every day.
Yes.
(upbeat music)
(audience cheering)
$5000.
Congratulations.
(audience reaction masks conversation)
Do you mind sharing this story with us?
Nicole, you're getting emotional and I was wondering why,
since we've all been sharing on this show together.
Because when COVID first hit and we had to shut down,
I had to shut down my tax business
and I actually got sick for seven weeks
and I lost $17,000.
And because of having to go virtual and stuff,
I never was able to recoup it.
So this means so much.
This is Karma.
(audience clapping)
Well then I have to throw in an extra $10,000.
That's right, we're gonna right this wrong.
(audience cheering)
I'm so sorry that that happened to you,
but let's fix it right now, okay?
You are everything that you, oh my gosh.
Thank you Nicole, for sharing your story.
Thank you so much, thank you.
(audience cheering)
Thank you Nicole.
Thank you, oh my gosh.
Well, well that was, that was fun.
(all laughing)
I mean it, this place, this show
has something really wonderful about it.
So thank you for choosing to spend your time with us.
That is an honor.
And that goes for everybody watching at home and on the go.
Thank you so much. And we hope that we see you soon.
Take this with you.
(upbeat music)